[Musica]
la sera sono massimiliano e insegue
sogni
vi spiego in questo periodo della mia
vita sono a parte particolarmente
critica di un percorso che è iniziato
due anni e mezzo fa e che sta per
portare sul mercato un prodotto che
abbiamo realizzato con una startup
jolene e allora visto che questo
percorso ancora non ha dato esito
piuttosto che parlare di questa
avventura di questo mio sogno
preferisco condividere con voi quella
che è la mia visione del futuro di
internet perché è una cosa che secondo
me riguarderà tutti noi e tutti voi in
tempi non troppo lunghi e quindi per
open doors percorsi di storie future
io vi parlerò della mia visione del
futuro di internet allora può abbassare
un pò di crawford cosa sarà il futuro di
internet
io sinceramente non lo so perché non ho
la sfera di cristallo quindi vorrei con
voi condividere un po di idee che forse
potranno darci un'immagine di questa
cosa
secondo me il futuro di internet sarà un
futuro
bello ma con sempre meno web perché un
futuro bello perché non credo nelle
distopia tecnologiche quindi vedete
negli anni cinquanta noi ci immaginavo
un futuro molto diverso da quello che
poi è stato
immaginate per un attimo come sarebbe
applicare nella vita di tutti i giorni
in tutti i campi della nostra attività
dal dal sociale nell'intimità nella vita
di tutti i giorni quello che è tutto il
nostro sapere scientifico in maniera
critica diretta brada quindi
alimentazione calibrata forse tipo
astronauta riproduzione scientifica
magari basata su metodi in vitro
tempistiche della giornata divisa in
maniera razionale però non è così non è
andata così
se ci pensate noi siamo molto più simili
ai nostri predecessori ai nostri cari
antichi romani nel modo di vivere il
modo di socializzare nel modo di vivere
il tempo
libero andare fuori mangiare fuori
sarebbe strada e ci avevano provato però
a un certo punto a inquadrare la società
in una diciamo così una tecnocrazia
molto razionale dove si faceva
eugenetica dove si faceva selezione
della razza dove si facevano tante cose
che erano più guidate da un approccio
scientifico razionale piuttosto che dal
nostro essere uomini
e però no non è andata cosa ha vinto ha
vinto l'uomo perché finché sarà l'amore
a far andare avanti il mondo come
ragione di base non dobbiamo più
preoccuparsi di cose aberrante di un
futuro che è contro l'uomo di un futuro
che è distopico ecco perché penso che il
futuro di internet sarà un futuro bello
perché con meno web
pensate vent'anni fa quello che dicevano
sociologi della nostra vita ora con l'e
commerce non riuscirete mai più di casa
staremo sempre in casa ordineremo tutto
quello che ci serve dalla nostra
scrivania ci isoleremo dietro questi
monitor non avremo più vita sociale
peccato che ad oggi questo è un
qualsiasi lo capsule parole più cercate
su internet c'è il tempo per uscire per
andare in giro per divertirsi traduzioni
per viaggiare per comprendere
informazioni che vengono da posti
lontani mappe informazioni cose che
servono per vita sociale per uscire per
muoversi un pericolo scampato quindi non
sarà un futuro fatto di cyborg di cose
distopiche sarà un futuro bello e meno
web
cos'è l'uso di internet come ci siamo
abituati è sedersi al computer aprire le
pagine studiare leggere e navigare in
maniera esclusiva io escludo dalla mia
realtà quello che mi sta intorno e mi
concentro su quello che guardo sul web
questa cosa secondo me sparirà saremo
sempre meno assorti dentro un
contenitore è sempre più internet sarà
un metodo per avere informazioni che
saranno un altro strato della nostra
realtà quotidiana nel nostro percepire
la realtà daranno delle informazioni in
più
a quello che noi abbiamo intorno e
quindi non c'è strane remo chiude dietro
un monitor ma saremo in certo senso
capace di vedere cose che vanno oltre
già adesso ci sono delle parti di
internet che non si parla più solo di
web ma di internet of things che
significa che alla rete che collega
connette permette il traffico di
informazioni non ci sono più solo
persone che guardano dentro un monitor
contenuti fatti da altre persone ma ci
sono degli oggetti che ci aiutano a fare
sì che le nostre città siano più smart
che le nostre azioni abbiano dei
riflessi sul mondo che ci circonda per
esempio per avere una temperatura più
gradevole una stanza a consumare meno
energia e fare in modo che le nostre
città siano più accoglienti verso di noi
un po come e gli organismi viventi si
adattano nei confronti dell'ambiente che
la circonda
un'altra cosa un altra parola importante
che ci dice che qualcosa sta cambiando
dalla fruizione del web a altro è
l'avvento del web all sono dei
dispositivi che noi portiamo addosso e
che non sono più isolati come quelle di
una volta il monile piuttosto che il
bracciale l'orologio ma sono connessi ci
permettono di avere informazioni da
situazioni completamente diverse dal
nostro corpo ma anche di riflettere
condizione del nostro corpo nel nostro
ambiente
quindi con questi dispositivi già stiamo
sperimentando già oggi un'interazione
diversa con quello che ci che ci
circonda
come è nato il tutto è nato con pochi
computer difficilmente accessibili poi
siamo passati a tanti personal computer
ma isolati tra di loro e poi ci siamo
abituati ad essere connessi però in
maniera esclusiva portando la nostra
realtà direttamente dentro al monitor
escludendo quello che c'era intorno un
po come capita anche come in dispositivi
mobile adesso nella nostra realtà a
volte diversa da quella che c'è intorno
bene questo non avverrà più ma
semplicemente noi vivremo le nostre
esperienze con delle informazioni che
vengono dall'esterno fuse con la nostra
diciamo così realtà sensoriale
ci sono delle interfacce io non ho a
fare questa non so come sarà però già
oggi ci sono delle dell'interfaccia che
ci aiutano in questo questi sono i
glassa è un prodotto italiano che viene
fatta a modena e che permette nel campo
visivo della persona che la indossa di
avere dell'informazione in
sovraimpressione
quindi ho già in questo momento possa
avere uno strato sopra la mia realtà di
informazioni che vengono da internet
quest altro oggetto se volete
complementare si chiama brien controllo
e permette attraverso la reazione dei
neuroni che diceva prima professor
famiglia di attuare dei comandi
semplicemente pensando in questo questa
slide cioè mio amico pasquale fedele che
sta comandando un drone con il suo
pensiero
quindi noi potremmo andare oltre i sensi
senza droghe di sintesi ma andare oltre
i nostri sensi ed avere un rapporto che
dove ci porterà questo a noi alla
condivisione internet non sarà più un
qualcosa che ci tiene isolati che ci
tiene dietro a un monitor nella nostra
bolla personale ma sarà sempre di più
uno strumento che ci renderà in grado di
condividere esperienze come sede
vivessimo insieme potremo scegliere cosa
percepire in più di quello della realtà
che ci circonda e come gestirlo
immaginate poi quali sono le
applicazioni in campo medico
un'equipe può operare pur non essendo
fisicamente nella stessa stanza
scambiarsi le esperienze oppure operare
in un'arteria che è grande come una
galleria stradale senza avere più il
problema di quello che è il fare
qualcosa che potrebbe essere
potenzialmente letale
oppure in ambito tecnico io sto
manutenendo un sistema che è
estremamente complicato
prima avevo delle difficoltà perché
dovevo ricordarmi tutto portarmi dietro
tonnellate di manualistica per capire
tutti i singoli componenti cosa stanno
facendo potremo interagire magari
direttamente col progettista ed avere
manutentore e progettista come se
stessero lavorando allo stesso impianto
nello stesso momento oppure nell'ambito
di costruzione di macchine
il movimento terra e qualsiasi altra
cosa che ha a che fare con la
realizzazione di cose in equipe potremo
operare non essendo fisicamente la
quindi in miniera nei cantieri in tutte
le situazioni dove c'è un pericolo ma
necessità di un operatore umano come per
esempio negli impianti subacquee dove
c'è da riparare delle condotte che sono
difficilmente raggiungibili invece di
mandare esseri umani noi potremo
interagire e controllare con degli
strumenti che stiamo cominciando a
sviluppare quindi quale sarà il futuro
di internet
non lo so ma penso che sarà un futuro
bello e con sempre meno web
[Musica]